we all have do you have can you show me
a little yeah we can show you like a
second of it we don't wait don't wait
oh you want showing that much okay to
stop boiler alert red hands ready wait
wait on three one two three that's not
how long we did it how long we yesterday
know it was the day before that's when
we did it before
so hours of rehearsal is there any
concern that you know the judges I've
talked to a couple of them they're
concerned about the numbers being thrown
off on the panel tonight what I'm just
telling there says there's real concern
let's get your scores Carrie Ann Inaba
Kevin Hart
Juliane hub
Bruno Tonioli here's the thing keV and
I've talked about this several times I I
have a dancing background me coming from
where I come from a little thing called
Pistol Pete have you ever seen it you
ever seen this trophy I don't want to
see piss well mr. Pearce offensive plays
ever done go show me a little bit
I won't fine pistol piss don't get that
Pete don't get that Pete it was a whole
thing it was me my the kiss how did you
work with this guy for so long because
clearly after a while you know yeah no
headphones thank you to end and a good
playlist on your iPod get you through a
day so when Kevin's talking anything
it's no please don't Pistol Pete you're
listening to like you know Run DMC or
like you're listening to of Tupac you're
just you're you're jamming to your own
stuff but Kevin believes that you're
dancing it was what about me what about
me dealing with Julia singing oh let's
Broadway loosing a look means this
Broadway voice when they're working with
cannons the hardest thing hardest thing
I've ever done that Broadway voice yeah
that's that's a new show that I'm
writing a call working with Kevin is the
hardest hardest thing hardest thing I've
ever done yeah we're still workshopping
it